a guy by the name of andrew tate who i
had never heard of until a couple weeks
ago he's a big uh british kickboxer who
has sort of become like a i don't know
like a bit of a younger this is going to
be a crazy comparison at some level but
like a younger jordan peterson in that
he's talking to young men about getting
their lives in order uh he's garnered
millions and millions of views he's huge
across everything well basically about
two weeks ago he was canceled everywhere
youtube took them out facebook took him
out instagram took him out tick tock
took him out everyone took this guy out
and of course when they do a coordinated
assassin assassination like that you
know something's up it's like is this
guy really a hater is he teaching people
to hate women is he teaching people to
be terrorists or be really mean or
anything like that or is he possibly
just saying something about maybe about
personal responsibility that kind of
stuff that's usually what'll get you
canceled these days well anyway andrew
tate he was canceled on all of these
things
and he went on tucker carlson about a
week ago to discuss his banning andrew
tate is a former kickboxer who's built
up a truly enormous following on social
media until a couple months ago we'd
never heard of him and then the other
day
virtually every tech company on the
planet banned him not just his presence
but also his ability to conduct business
on the internet he was taken off
instagram tick tock facebook youtube all
of it
then they started telling you that not
only was he not allowed to talk but you
weren't allowed to like him because he
was an incredibly bad person i don't
really feel like i've exposed anything
like i'm truly
not a very political person this is the
first time someone's experienced this
level of ban i'm not particularly right
wing i don't vote i mean i obviously
have my own personal views but they
didn't ban me for that
um they banned me simply because
i had large swaths of the population
agreeing to very traditional masculine
values
teenage men and young and young men 20
30 22 23 24
were looking up to me and aspiring to be
like me i have a very traditionally
masculine life
i have fast cars in a big house and a
lot of money and a beautiful girlfriend
and they thought they thought this was
very very threatening and for some
reason they decided that it's better if
they annihilate me from the internet and
replace me with somebody who's more
aligned with
whatever they're trying to purport
okay so what's super interesting about
this and i would welcome you to google
this guy and try to find out what his
crazy
dangerous evil views are is you can tell
even just in that you know 30 seconds
that he's talking there this guy is not
a hater he's somebody that's living his
life uh he is proud of how he lives he
believes that men are men women are
women that personal responsibility means
something that success is not evil and
then the way they do the coordinated
assassination now you remember the
coordinated assassination this is what
they did to alex jones this is what they
did to donald trump when it's not like
oh instagram just has an internal
meeting and they're like okay we're
going to get rid of them but they all
figure out a way to do it within days
and not only can they do it to people
but of course they can also do it to
websites remember parlor
so we know that this sort of thing
happens and i this morning as i was
doing cardio i was googling andrew tate
trying to find all the hateful things
that he said and i couldn't find it so
it's interesting because now this guy
has become sort of the center of the
firestorm he's got rogan talking about
it now he's got everybody talking about
well what's going on here what are the
views that you're not allowed to have on
these big tech platforms well here are
some of his views
tell us what your message is to young
men
yeah so i think that being a man is very
very difficult i think that men's issues
are largely overlooked
the people in charge of the world
pretend to care but when somebody who's
champion champion championing men's
issues like myself comes forward and
finally manages to garner huge
percentiles of the public support i'm
silenced so they're not really
interested in men's issues and there's a
lot of young men growing up today that
feel very disaffected they feel
invisible
the agendas that are being forced down
their throats are not agendas they align
with or they feel affinity to or agendas
they want
and i basically just say to men look
it's a very hard life
you're gonna need to get up work hard go
to the gym strong body is a strong mind
you're going to have to reject
listening blindly to everything you're
told reject the slave mind think for
yourself get a strong network of
brothers work aside them don't tolerate
low quality people in your life which
means don't tolerate men who just smoke
drugs and play video games or men who
are disloyal or dishonest by extension
don't tolerate women or girlfriends who
are disloyal or dishonest and try and
build and create a reality full of high
quality people in which you can resist
the programming that the matrix tries to
influence you with and grow up true
man does some of that sound kind of
familiar kind of jordan peterson kind of
obvious like live an honest life take
care of yourself realize that it's hard
out there but it's on you to figure
things out and in some ways that is the
scariest message to the machine the
machine wants you compromised and fat
and watching porn all the time and
eating unhealthy and not doing anything
for yourself and constantly needing more
of it so the message of self-empowerment
whether you're empowering men or women
is this most dangerous thing that is the
most dangerous thing for the people that
want to control you